BEATRICE PELTE: So the
book is over there.
So I don't have a copy now here.
But yes, so this is my second
book entitled "My French Family
Table."
And often, when I'm asked
what's the difference
between the first one
and the second one,
is the first one was focusing
more on introducing recipes
that I know to do across.
And it was actually
divided by occasions.
Whereas this one, four years
later, focuses more on family.
And a title "French
Family Table,"
meaning that the food is
obviously French by essence.
And specifically
for the book and
for the general understanding
of French cuisine,
I wanted specifically
to try to educate people
to understanding that
French cuisine is not
necessarily only meaning
fine dining and elegant.
As a matter of
fact, French people
eat very simple
things every day.
This book is a translation
of the kind of work flow, so
to speak, of how a typical
French family would eat,
which obviously
sounds very cliche.
But it is our reality every day.
In 2002, I had one daughter.
In 2016, we have two children.
So it even made more sense to
write this book because for me,
educating my children
to taste and good food
is a strong part
of their education.
So I really wanted this
book to focus on that.
So when you look
at the book, you
will see that the book
follows the rhythm of our day,
from breakfast recipes to lunch.
And my typical lunch would be
a savory tart, salad, soups.
That's typically
what we enjoy eating.
There's a section focusing
on cooking with my daughter
specifically, because obviously,
Remy is too small for that yet.
But I want to share the
passion I have to including her
in cooking food.
So there's a whole
section devoted to that.
There's a section talking
about the typical snack
that French people
do, which typically
happens at 4:00 PM
every day after school.
There's a section
on main courses,
and obviously on
desserts, because I
love to make desserts.
One thing that is worth
noting, but is not
necessarily the main
focus of my book,
but I want to
mention it more also
for the second than the first.
It turns out that all
the recipes in the book
are gluten free.
And the reason why
I don't want this
to be the focus because
for me, the focus has
to be on enjoyment of
food and not on saying,
this is a special diet.
As a matter of fact, when
people come to the house,
I never emphasize that
the book is gluten free
or the recipes are gluten free.
It's all about sharing a moment
together around the table.
So that's something that
now, especially, I've
been eating gluten free
for more than 10 years.
And 10 years ago, things
were very different from what
they are today.
And I know that now,
there's way more emphasis
and having a gluten
free diet is more--
I want to say it's the norm, but
it's more like, oh yeah, right.
It's more available
and accessible.
So that's something
that now we actually
added on the subtitle
of the book as well.
The first one didn't
have that byline.
So for today, I
chose a recipe that
is very flexible
in the sense of it
is a chocolate cake that I
have included in the chocolate
section of the book.
Because at home, we
eat a lot of chocolate.
We love chocolate every season.
There's no season for chocolate.
So here we are July.
And every day, there's a
chocolate cake at the house.
The reason why this
cake is very interesting
is because it's got
three components.
It's got the chocolate
base cake, a decoration
made of mascarpone cheese and
very simple with a bit of sugar
and whipped cream, and decorated
with fresh raspberries.
And the reason why this recipe
is very welcome in any kitchen,
I find, is I use a chocolate
cake base as an everyday cake.
As a matter of fact, I make
this chocolate cake every week
at the house, something
that I like to nibble on
throughout the day.
And I'm not kidding.
I do that.
And then when you have friends
coming over for a meal,
it's nice to actually have
something more decorated.
So I use the other
two pieces, which
is the mascarpone cheese
element and the raspberries,
to dress it up.
The recipes in the book are
actually designed this way.
I like to take an
everyday recipe.
And if I need to transform it
into something more dressed up,
I can with little
touches to finish a dish.
So I'm not going to
give example now.
But if you looked
throughout the book,
some main courses
are designed this way
where you would have something
that the whole family enjoys,
children included, because
there's nothing that separates
children from adult food.
But some touches that would be
more complicated for children
can be added.
So you don't have to think
about two different menus
when you have
people coming over.
Nobody likes that.
I mean, at home, I try not
to do that whenever possible.
So the cake.
This is a chocolate cake made
with buckwheat and hazelnut.
So it is gluten free, as I said.
It uses chocolate here.
It uses butter and eggs,
hazelnut meal, buckwheat,
and what else?
A little bit of fleur de sel for
the chocolate base and that's
pretty much it.
And then for the decoration, I
have mascarpone, whipped cream,
and raspberries.
And finishing touches
with confectioner's sugar.
So I'm going to start with
my chocolate and my sugar.
But at home, I usually
put everything by weight.
Something that is
specified in the book
is always a measure and
weight of every ingredient
you have for accuracy.
So you need roughly-- I
have the recipe here--
but I put here 125 grams.
125, little more.
And the sugar.
I have here 70 grams.
Depending also-- at
home, not to be biased,
but I do use a lot of
the Valrhona chocolate.
And I like to look at the cocoa
contents of the chocolate.
So my favorites are between
66% to 70% cocoa contents.
If you use 66, you might
actually want a bit less sugar.
If you use 70%, you want to
have a little more sugar.
I play it by whatever
chocolate is handy.
But roughly, you want between
70 and 80 grams of sugar.
80 grams of butter.
So you melt that.
So then three eggs.
Put the eggs in.
That's where the sugar goes.
So here, I don't know what's
the content of that chocolate.
But I'll put roughly 80 grams.
So you put that in here.
You want a texture
that's going to be
creamy and light in color.
So you can leave that
unattended and then
let it do its thing
while you prepare that
and measure the rest
of the ingredients.
I'm done with this.
And I'm now going to measure the
buckwheat flour, the hazelnuts,
and the fleur de sel.
What's nice about
fleur de sel, it just
adds a little bit
of specks of salt
to the finer taste of
the chocolate base.
So I need about 40
grams of each flour.
That's the buckwheat.
I like to use buckwheat with
chocolate specifically recipes.
And then hazelnut.
And this is hazelnut.
You could use almond.
If people are allergic to nuts,
you could use quinoa, millet.
And if it's not important
to eat gluten free,
you can use even regular flour.
The buckwheat is actually
nice for taste factor.
But you could use all purpose
flour as well instead of
the nuts.
But the nuts actually add a
very good texture to the cake.
A little fleur de sel here.
And I keep that for later.
Then I just have to watch
how everything is doing.
Just waiting for the chocolate
to melt with the butter.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious
about the gluten thing.
When I lived in France,
flour was everywhere--
real flour, wheat flour--
bread, pastry, and so on.
Has the gluten free
fad hit France?
BEATRICE PELTE: It's starting.
It's not going to be
as prevailing in places
like the US or even Ireland.
My parents-in-law are Irish.
And there's a lot of people
that actually-- I'm not celiac,
but there's a lot of people that
are actually celiac in Ireland.
So It's very easy to get
everything gluten free,
including bread in restaurants.
In France, you
would not find that.
So it is still a
challenge for me.
But you get used to
doing without it.
AUDIENCE: It's hard to imagine
eating in France without bread.
BEATRICE PELTE:
But you can make--
I mean, I made my own bread.
So, I mean, yes, I don't
eat a baguette the same way,
and there are things that
I don't cook the same way.
But there's a lot of foods that
are gluten free in essence.
So when you go to a
restaurant, definitely people
are educated to it.
They would always accommodate.
But they would not
have replacements
for-- let's say there's
restaurants in the Boston area
where they actually even
serve gluten free bread,
good restaurants.
But in France, that
would be a little,
I think, too much to ask.
So move over here things.
I'm going to turn that down.
So this is nice, light in color.
So I'm going to
put that in here.
This is what I have now here.
And then I'm going just to
basically use this spatula
to just mix it in together.
AUDIENCE: Can you just leave
it out during the week?
BEATRICE PELTE: Yeah.
It doesn't last very long.
AUDIENCE: But at
some point, do you
need to put it in the fridge?
BEATRICE PELTE: Yeah.
I mean, if it's hot weather
like that, I would definitely.
In winter I wouldn't need to.
But when it's hot and it's
really muggy like this,
I would put it in the fridge.
But then I would actually
take it out of the fridge.
It's nicer eaten
at room temperature
because, obviously, the fridge
is going to make it harder.
It's not actually
unpleasant by any means,
but it just alters the texture,
definitely, makes it harder.
More like-- almost
like a kind of-- it
loses the moisture of it.
As a matter of fact, I made
one-- what day is today?
Tuesday?
I made one-- I forget when.
Sunday maybe.
Yes, when it was very hot.
Sunday.
When it was a little
less hot, Sunday.
And I put it in the
fridge last night.
And I ate a slice earlier
this morning at 11:00 AM
with a cup of tea.
Normally, you would
put parchment paper
for easiness of removing the
cake or cutting it better.
But especially if
you have a nice pan
at home, a ceramic pan,
you could actually bake it.
You just butter it generously.
And then you just
put the batter in it.
And so you notice there's no
yeast or anything or baking
powder in it.
So it is not a cake that's
going to be very high,
rise very much.
And then you preheat
your oven at 350.
And then you put that in your
oven for 25 to 30 minutes.
That's it.
And depending-- the one
that I make at home,
my pan is a little different.
So actually, it's
a little higher.
I actually use a
rectangular pan.
And then you just
basically eat it like that.
Or then you're going to end
up slicing it for tasting.
So you're going to cut
it in small squares.
That's just like
this to demonstrate.
When I serve it as a
dessert for guests,
I like to actually
cut slices like this.
And you can see that actually
in the picture in the book.
And so that's a bigger size.
And basically, I would
pipe the mascarpone,
I would use a tip that actually
has a little decoration.
And you would pipe, let's
say, six pieces here
with six raspberries on top.
So I can demonstrate
with that as well.
The next step is using
mascarpone and whipped cream.
So I have both here
prepared for me.
This mascarpone is
lightly sweetened
with confectioner's sugar.
The whipped cream here has
this nice, firm texture.
And you basically
combine both together so
that the mascarpone
is not too dense
and the whipped cream
makes it a little lighter.
And then you get this,
which is always better
if it's a little-- on
days like today, if I
was to leave this out, it
would become a little too soft.
So I try to keep it in the
fridge as long as possible
so that it doesn't
soften, especially
with the whipped cream.
And then you just
pipe in a little bit.
Actually I'm going to do-- And
then I have my raspberries.
And then the last piece would
be to use confectioner's sugar.
What I would do at
home also is add
a little bit of cocoa powder.
Or you know what
you could do also?
Which I always have a
box of that at home.
If you're familiar
with cocoa nibs,
cocoa nibs are beautiful in
a lot of different ways--
on finishes like this,
or even with granola
or any kind of yogurty dessert.
But anyway, confectioner's
sugar always makes things nicer,
I find.
It's a cloud of happiness.
See?
Gives it life.
And then after that, you
would do exactly the same
with a bit of cocoa
powder like this.
And then you could put-- well,
imagine I have cocoa nibs.
I would put cocoa nibs.
I could put some chopped
hazelnuts, and my little cloud
of cocoa powder.
Voila.
That's my recipe.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
Any questions?
AUDIENCE: So my
question is anytime
people ask me about foods
from my culture, my country,
I can tell them exactly
what I like to cook myself,
what my parents
cook for me, what
my two sets of grandparents
eat in restaurants at home,
and that's pretty much it.
So how do you do your research?
Or do you do any
research so that you
can have French cuisine
or French cookbook?
Or do you just like
present your own ideas?
BEATRICE PELTE: Well, food
has always been with me
for many, many years.
And so from being
a little girl, I
grew up in a very
small village in France
with very strong
home grown cooking.
So everyone had
vegetable gardens.
And food was really a
prevailing conversation at home.
So my memories of cooking
have been following me
through the years.
And so when I was
a little girl, I
kept actually little
notebooks where
I would cut recipes
from magazines
and stick them in them.
So it's not something that
just happened recently
when all of a sudden I
decided to write a book.
But having said that,
so it's something that's
been with me for a long time.
I'm pretty obsessed with food.
Let's put it this way.
But there's so many
ways to keep up
with what's happening in
your own home country,
including magazines.
I mean, I have two
that I'm subscribed to.
Being a blogger myself,
I know what's happening.
So I'm reading what's going on
in France on the food scene--
what people like to eat,
what the food trends are.
But it really depends
on the kind of memories
attached to your own food.
Where are you from?
AUDIENCE: Hungary.
BEATRICE PELTE: Hungary.
I still think there's
a lot of things
that you can explain and go
back to you have your childhood
memories.
I mean, magazines?
Are there Hungarian
food magazines?
Yeah.
So they definitely talk more
about what Hungarians eat.
And it's the same.
As a matter of fact, I got
a package from my mother
yesterday, including one
of my subscribed magazines.
And I can see,
right, summer comes.
Here comes the vegetable tarts.
Here comes the barbecued things
that are typical of France.
I mean, as an example, French
people would have a barbecue.
Americans would have a barbecue.
But they would eat
completely different things.
So it's just something
that is inside,
I think, educating
people to taste.
Even the way people
present food is different.
I think it's not difficult for
me to keep up with this here
because the accessibility
to ingredients is very easy.
There's nothing that
I feel short of.
In Boston, I find
pretty much everything
if I want to eat or cook
authentic French food.
But my cuisine-- and
I like to say that.
My food is not--
if you're expecting
to find in the book things like
blanquette de veau or boeuf
Bourguignon or those kind
of very traditional food
recipes, that's not so
much what I like to cook.
I like to focus more
on traditional recipes,
but with my own touches and
the modern way, so to speak.
So it's obviously catering
to the family needs.
Recipes are faster.
They are easier to make.
It's not going to be
boeuf Bourguignon that
takes four hours to cook.
That's not the kind of
cuisine I offer in the book.
It's more catering
to everyday at home.
So it's really what we eat.
Does that answer your question?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Did you find
that, moving to the US,
you had to alter the
way that you cook some
just because of-- just
ovens are different
or the pans are different?
BEATRICE PELTE:
Well, I know people
a lot talk about some
ingredients like flour,
butter is different.
And actually, I am friends with
people at the Vermont Butter
and Cheese Company.
And my friend Adleen,
who is actually
in charge of a big production
part of making cheese and cream
and everything, always tells
me butter is a big deal.
And it's never going
to be the same.
But I find adjusting
very easy, actually.
If I was really scientific
about food, more so,
especially with baking--
making a baguette or all
those kind of
things-- possibly I
would find flours
more challenging.
But obviously, on my end,
because I also use other flour
than wheat-based ones, I
don't find any difference
or challenge.
As a matter of fact, one thing
that I really love moving here
was in France, as an
example, farmers markets
are very beautiful
in season, especially
in the south when you
travel there in the summer.
But people often
say, oh, there's
farmers markets throughout
the year in France.
But actually, if
you go to Paris,
and you go to those
marches outside,
and you actually look at the
labels where things come from,
a lot of them in
the middle of winter
are not coming from France.
They come from Morocco.
They come from Spain or
the Netherlands, wherever.
Whereas when I came
here, I remember
going to the farmers market
and thinking, Jesus, 10 stands.
That's ridiculous.
And I started really
understanding the whole concept
of the farmer's
market and why it's
so nice to have farmer's market
here because what you find
is what people produce.
And it's no things coming
from Spain or anywhere else.
It's basically what people make.
And I ended up preferring those
kind of markets to the ones
that-- even I'm from the
Northeastern part of France
where it's not like the
south, you can grow things
as much with abundance.
And you go to the
market and you really
find things are coming
from North Africa.
You know, bananas.
You find everything
at the market.
Well, nobody in
France grows bananas.
Whereas here, you go
to the farmer's market,
you just find what
people produce.
And I think that's much better.
That makes more sense.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So when you're
cooking for your family,
how long does it take?
And then how long do you
spend when people come over?
What's the difference?
BEATRICE PELTE: So how
long it takes to make.
And then sorry, the last part?
AUDIENCE: So how
long when you're
cooking just for your
family, versus how long
you're cooking when you're
entertaining guests.
BEATRICE PELTE: Well, it
depends what I obviously make.
But I would say, on
average, I would spend,
let's say, an hour
in the kitchen.
Obviously, when Remy
arrived, there was more chaos
at home with two children.
But as I said, I don't separate.
So I make one main course.
And that doesn't mean that
our daughter specifically
will like everything.
But we have a rule.
She needs to try everything,
sometimes reluctantly.
But that's OK.
We don't win at every battle.
There's always going to
be something she likes.
And then the rest is
pretty much a main course
that we can-- how do you say?
As an example, I
would make a risotto,
which from start to finish
is roughly 30 minutes.
You cook it for 20 minutes.
You have maybe 10 minutes prep.
And then with that,
I would make a salad.
And then maybe I would
have smoked salmon,
or I would have a piece of
fish, easy, like a baked fish.
You would have a piece
of nice wild salmon.
You oil with salt,
pepper, fresh herbs.
15 minutes in the oven.
You don't have to
think about it.
And then a green salad,
and you have dinner.
When guests come, obviously,
it can go from very quick
like this to I have to be
in the kitchen all day.
And I do that.
I like when my husband asks
me, oh yeah, let's go hiking
this morning and do this.
Or let's go do the
shopping in the morning.
I'm thinking, you're
out of your mind.
I have people coming tonight.
I'm not going shopping
in the morning.
I'm not doing all those
things in the morning.
I have to focus on the food.
I organize my day around that.
I prep a cold soup that
has to sit in the fridge.
And then I can finish the
main course in the evening.
And the dessert typically,
if it's something like this,
the base would be
baked in the morning
and I can assemble
in the evening.
But I love what I do.
So obviously,
cooking is something
that I'm not shy
spending time doing.
But the recipes in the
book are definitely
offering a variety
of lengths and times.
What I love about the
books, even more so
this one than the first one,
is it's a very lived in book.
It's like we live
with it every day.
As a matter of fact,
which is very rare for me
to go back to my
own recipes, but I
take my own book from the
shelf and I cook from it.
And it's like, yeah, the
first one, I can retest.
Yeah, they work.
That's a big deal.
And second, this is really the
food or the recipes we eat,
whether it's for us
or when people come.
And I really like that about it.
It's really a used book.
Because, like every
person who does what I do,
I own a lot of books at home.
And do I cook from them?
Probably not from most of them.
I mean, I'm a photographer.
So I like to take time
looking and getting
inspired by what other
people do, how they do it.
But it's nice to have
a book that I can
go back to and use every day.
AUDIENCE: If you're blogging
and working on social media,
do you keep a schedule
for yourself on what days
you do that?
BEATRICE PELTE: Right.
Well, that's what I
would want-- OK, I
was able to do that probably
two, three years ago.
The last few years, the
last year and a half
have been more challenging.
So I'm slowly getting back
into trying, step by step,
first to go back to blogging.
And things have
changed so much also.
When I started, all
there was, was blogs.
And I think one of the
first food bloggers.
I'm not the first exactly,
but among the first food
blogs that exist.
Now there's so many more blogs.
Even for me, it's very hard
to keep up with everything
that's out there.
And things have changed.
So myself, I migrated to
become an avid blogger
to a more avid Instagrammer.
And because what I
do is very visual,
Instagram is very gratifying
because I can do snap,
and my picture tells a story
of what's happening in my life
right now.
So my readership
I think migrated
from many people
following my blog--
and they still exist--
to people that now
follow me a lot on Instagram.
I think on Instagram,
which happened
for different
reasons-- I don't know
the truth of how
people sometimes
get so many followers.
But sometimes along
the way-- and I
know I've been featured
a few times on Instagram,
so that always helps, obviously.
But I have something
like 60,000 followers,
which started from 0 to 60.
And I think people migrate
themselves from Facebook
to Twitter and blogs still, but
it takes more time with a blog,
depending on what kind
of content you deliver.
I tend to want a nice
story with a nice picture.
So to produce that for
me takes more time.
So I don't have right now a
very tight schedule on that.
I am hopeful to go back
to something better.
But my reality right now
is I don't have the time.
Because I do this.
I have the book, but
I have my own clients.
I do a lot of editorial work.
I do commercial work.
This is how I have a living.
The blog is very nice.
The blog is supporting my
work, but I'm not generating
a lot of revenue with a blog.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
I think you can sample
food and I can sign books.